こんにちははじめしゃちょーで今日はねちょっとまたマニアックな数打つんですけど
8トンボさんからの新しいシャーペンです
俺のです
ちなみに
良い方です2種類あるんですよ普通ノールのとグレードが高めのオールグリップを追っ
て芯を出すって言う
グリップ太めですよ
a 600円ましたっけろっぴろっ600や実は俺の一回買ったことあるんですよ俺俺
のスイフトってそれの上位バージョンで最近行っ最近だよね最近でたんですけど正直俺
のはあんまり好きじゃなかったです
立っいさー最近な斜面でもフリー機能が常備されてるんですよ
出身がでやつとか絶対俺のより早いと思って阿蘇マリネ好きじゃなかったんですけど
上位バージョンでたということで今回買わせていただきました
開けやすかった
うん
グリップが
グリップが良い桜もついもうちょいピント
来たっ
はいと言うかつです a 先はやっぱ精鋭ず経営ですねどっちかと言ったら
正確に書くタイプです
のん
すぎやという
こうやって芯を出すですよ子
すごいな要素こんなを考えつくなって
グリップもラバーグリップで持ちやすいんで使いにくいと思います
やっぱねー
最近同額ちょっとふざけ過ぎてそろそろちょっと1対1回落ち着きましょう
ちょっと
あまり好笑に忘れて来たらうまく飽きちゃうんで
ドクターグリップと同じくらいですね
なんと結構得ゲー使ってる人は結構使いやすいと思います
比較的軽いです軽いカレーかでかい親指クイッとするだけの頃
線が出ます
これは良い書きやすいですよ
カウンター
これ俺ちょっと待ってこれ俺ありがとう
ああああああ
似合ってるねやってるからいいけど結論から寄せていただきます非常に書きやすいです
フルのように振るのも飛んでるんですよ試験通過たかば必ずもう
そして出資でやろうかってもう奴もいたんですけどこれからあんまり
音でないから何が目当てにもならないと思うんで
か悔しいです
これはしばらくスタメンだな俺どんな上いくら3 e 2はこれはあり
かけやすいグリップも柔らかいし
いや俺なんかこんな
あんまり
あんまりもそろえばせない動画だけどすごいなんぞビットは最中今日
良い買い物したっすオルドネ上位ばあさん6編でウソでしょ
そんなしてっ気600円更新ラインでちょっと高いですけど頑張って買ってみては
いかがでしょうか
万寿台勉強はかどりますもうこれ付けはもう豪華者様
思うんですよぜひ買ってみてくださいじゃ
ん
me